sorry guys I know I'm an old man and I
know that nah man wash too bro
you are yeah I'm washed - what is it
wash me you see like I knew that was
gonna come what is wash me
I've watched is just like washed up you
know like I could like people in hip-hop
if you're just like you know Cher like
old school views and stuff right just be
like I'm washed all right write it down
that's my terminology my table when
you're like 30 you're pretty much washed
right you know what I mean cuz it's like
a youth driven in Oh give me a slang
that I wouldn't hear and then I'm gonna
say I'm say somebody say something like
hey have you heard of this and I'm gonna
say something go ahead have you heard of
washed no I was gonna say I'm wrong yeah
hey you wash now I'm now washed yeah it
makes no sense you know what dude you
got to go back to improv classes hey
here to bump and grind oh [ __ ] man I
don't know about that I washed that work
now cuz bump and grind is like an old
school yeah so you wouldn't mark out the
understanding that you know what I mean
why bumping grind is already washed you
know to me it's from a I'll believe this
what if I was like I was frozen now I'll
give you example let's say Bobby Lee was
an N arc and I can't do my hike one of
my hiking expeditions the ones you do
every Sun right an avalanche comes on
top of me right I freeze right and then
40 years later they find a way to
defrost my body right I awaken
right and then they say yo you know
about bump and grind and then I could
say I washed well they would have to
introduce you to the word washed first
and then you would use it right I [ __ ]
it all up
all right well then I'm not washed right
I don't know if you were like a young
kid in the future and you went back in
time used it then that what a world
yeah yeah so that's new terminal what
who makes these up men honestly like I
pretty much just learned that too like
I'm pretty washed you know what I mean
but I was like oh this is something like
I could say about myself you know yeah
just roast me how about this the last
year what are some new thing terminology
that's last year I want to see if I've
heard of all this past year yeah I don't
know if there's wouldn't it woke happen
I don't like using woke I know cuz I
already washed to be wolf but the word
woke and using it is like woke is
considered kind of corny at this point
yeah yeah I mean like okay okay like we
said welcome we said woke in front of
black people he be like Shh all right I
think it's just kind of corny you know
yeah
how about arm lit oh my god that's a
soul that's white culture and it's been
around forever and it's still being used
yeah I feel like is it just like part of
the book at vocab now yeah you know yeah
I don't know I think it might I don't
even know how to use it I mean yeah yeah
I need it though it's lit you can say a
party's lit you can say food is little
taking a bath man he was lit yeah yeah
yeah when when is a bath a lit before
hey when you enjoy it when it was just
amazing extract that is what it just got
input into like regular terminology when
people started using it like that yeah
damn that Keisha's lit negative thing be
lit like um oh man I was at that party
that night and then um I don't know I
passed out and I was an alleyway and a
black guy was [ __ ] me in the ass it
was lit no don't you ate it well I hated
it
people will do it some [ __ ] that like
you kind of like it was obviously
terrible yeah you don't wanna admit it
was like you kind of like this yeah be
like oh man bro I was an ally but it was
kind of lit
oh I was kind of late yeah yeah I hear
that a lot
yeah idle it you know
[Music]